Desiree you and your co-writer Cecilia
adapted this film from a novel by Emily
Danforth I'm curious as to how you found
the book and how you guys made the
decision to focus the film largely on
basically the second half of Emily's
novel yeah so I read the book when it
first came out a publisher friend sent
it to me and thought I would like it and
I loved it and I shared it with every
woman in my life and I've seen make it
so gendered I mean every lesbian in my
life and I shared it with my girlfriend
at the time who loved it too and said
you need to make this into a movie and
my incident thought was fear because the
book was so good and the tone was so
pitch perfect it danced beautifully
between tragedy and comedy and to me it
was the first really honest depiction of
teen life I'd read in a book and it
reminded me of John Hughes film and the
teen films I had grown up on and I was
really intimidated by that task because
you know 80% of the work I had done like
consisted of mainly fart jokes so I put
it aside for a while and then I made my
first feature film which was you know
super low budget and put together with
like spit and good intentions and favors
from friends and then I after when I was
traveling on the festival circuit with
that film my producing partner said what
do you want to do next and I was like
okay not next this is a book read it
love it and then in ten years
let's earned the right to make it and
she read it and she said we're doing
this and got the rights and we wrote it
on spec I mean I can only imagine how
hard it must be just in general to
distill a novel into a 90-minute film
you asked that how you decided to kind
of just look at the second half of the
book ya know from the get-go I knew I
didn't want to focus on the whole book I
had no interest in telling so the books
start the books 500 pages long and it
starts when Cameron's 11 and it ends
when she's 17 and the last 200
pages take place at God's promise the
center she sent - I always knew I wanted
to focus on that just the dramatic
archive it was so much more condensed I
hate biopics I hate it when movies go
and yeah it just feels like a watered
down version of someone's whole life I
knew that I liked I loved a queen in the
way that was condensed I wanted to make
a very condensed narrative that focused
on one very specific moment in this
girl's life that was emblematic of what
it was to be a teenager
Kolak would you have been ready to play
aged 11 had Desiree decided to do the
book from start to finish for each of
you what do you think it means to the
film that it does take place 25 years
ago obviously it's pre social media
which i think is really interesting but
for how do you think that informs the
film or changes the film that it's 1993
as opposed to 2013 well for me I just
wanted to keep them as isolated as
possible like the book takes place in 93
and it would have been more affordable
for us to shoot it now but at the end of
the day if they had any connection to
the outside world or any idols it would
have changed the feeling they're so
alone they have no idea of what life
could look like as a functioning
homosexual and I was important to me I
grew up Iranian with a conservative
Iranian parents and when I came out of
the closet it was like coming out as a
frickin leprechaun parents were like
what is that Medina's odd the president
at the time had just publicly announced
that there were no it was in Iran yeah
you went to Columbia and he was like
that doesn't exist in my country it is
it's an ailment that's punishable by
stoning to this day and it was so
unheard of and that was the loneliness
of coming out of never having seen
someone who looked like me who was like
me and that was one of the elements of
the book that I love that I related to
so deeply so to change it to today would
have changed the meaning entirely and
obviously as an actor you're doing
period different periods all the time
Chloe but for you was what did you do to
explore a time frame that shockingly you
were not even the wife 25 years ago I
think you think more than then more than
just trying to graph it grasp a time
period I found it very interesting the
the juxtaposition of where we were
politically in America when we filmed
this movie compared to the 1993 setting
and how when we assign it when I signed
on to this movie we were living in Obama
era still it's a very different climate
in America I've always been a you know
an advocate for the LGBT community so
this was something that was very
important to me but in so many ways
you know we were a champion and movie
that didn't have the societal impact
that it did halfway through the project
when Donald Trump was elected and all of
a sudden I realized that not only were
we doing a beautiful piece that I think
depicts being a young gay person if for
the first time very adequately this is a
societally impactful rebellious movie
this is the highest form of activism
that you could do and the fact that it's
2018 and not much has changed when you
think back to the filming I mean the
cast is you've got these Tony winners
like Jennifer and John Gallagher you
have these people relative newcomers
like Forrest and Sasha
you've got Chloe Chloe when you think
about to the filming who kept you on
your toes the most of your fellow cast
members was there like a wild card I
think it was it was the perfect example
of an ensemble because we we didn't have
enough rehearsals to really know what we
were going into we just had to jump in
and we all did our rehearsals you know
the night before alone and then we had a
very finite amount of time in our data
shoot it so there was an energy that was
almost like being on stage with each
other and it was special because working
with someone like Sasha working with
someone like Forrest who were the same
age as me but I've I've acted for 15
years and
having their energy come in in a lot of
ways it it broke a self-awareness that I
have just naturally from being very
comfortable in front of the camera it
broke it down so they're not hitting
their marks and we're not you know we're
not doing things as strategically as
they would be done if you're with a
bunch of seasoned doctors which i think
is really important and it comes across
very organic and I think you can really
feel that in the film it's
unconventional and so I think that also
goes for Ashley Connor in the way that
she shot us it was very unconventional
you know we didn't have a locked-off
shot it wasn't you know when
establishing and then we go closer and
closer and closer it was let's just turn
over here and get this shot I felt like
everything was dictated by the tools in
our arsenal you know we were shooting at
a very little budget with a very
restricted amount of time with actors
who Chloe's done 60 films sasha has done
one she shot it in a van and she you
know when you tell her like you know
when you give her a specific instruction
she's like come again I mean she's great
like she figured it out and by the end
we were running like clockwork but at
the same time it was such a discrepancy
between all of us and our skill set but
also with our money and our time so what
was I mean this is my favorite way to
work to is sort of at the top the dasie
like all right these these are the pages
we need to accomplish these are the
people around us and these are the
problems you know we're missing these
props this weather problems happen you
know like you just make a checklist of
the problems and you're like what soup
can I make with these ingredients it's
my favorite way of cooking as well
you're like this is what's in the fridge
what am I gonna make and that's what I
mean a lot of it lives in the close-up
because Chloe's performance dictated
that because Ashley's handheld is like
butter and she could maneuver it quite
nicely you see like and that's one thing
I really love about directing is you're
a bit of a like a conductor you're like
okay your skill in art is in my art
department is like oh you do really good
props and like oh I saw your
clinton-gore graphic great let's use
that like you know everyone has
something else that they can bring to
the table and you get to decide where
the talent goes and when to bring it
down well this is a movie I think is
going to help
a lot of people so I congratulate both
of you Desiree and Chloe thank you so
much for being here